it doesn't matter who the president is
if somebody tries to shoot at the
president it's my job to protect him or
her or whoever it is Democrat Republican
it doesn't matter
[Music]
I actually think that unfortunately it
is the truth the war is a necessary evil
there will always be somebody out there
training to take whether it be your
rights the freedoms take land take over
countries to exert their dominance and
their therefore has to be somebody
willing to stand in that gap and say
nope not gonna happen one of the things
that I experienced when I got out was I
had a big problem with anger I was
constantly angry at people my PTSD was
through the roof and I had to learn how
to alternatively defuse situations that
I got myself into and so now I'm
thinking is war absolutely necessary or
is there another way that people can
work together whether they're from other
countries or not to resolve issues and
so that's why I chose to somewhat
disagree because I agree that yeah there
are situations where you have to step in
and wars are the only option because
maybe they're being hard-headed and you
just have to get the message across yeah
the word necessary it was kind of like
was weird for me because I was like
inevitable or necessary like from a
personal standpoint I think like not
stuffing not necessary you know in my
intellect tells me like no you can talk
it out and things like that but evil
exists in the world that's just a fact
it's not gonna go away ever so I think
it's it's not only necessary it's also
inevitable that we're gonna go to war
the military industrial complex is
actually a real thing it generates
business it generates revenue so there's
people that make money off of war and so
therefore it's going to happen I think
it's important for us to have liked this
country for us to have a presence in the
military you know to be around and
anywhere in the world because that you
were protecting ourselves and we're in
the long run maybe protecting other
countries you know my ship when we were
on deployment we rescued two hundred
eighty eight Nigerians from the middle
of the ocean their ship had caught on
fire and if we hadn't been there our
presence wasn't there they probably
would have all you know been stranded
out there and maybe hadn't even survived
and so I think it's important to have a
presence
it's hard to understand something from a
perspective of something you've never
experienced so like if you've never been
in the military chances are like you're
not gonna understand like you know the
intricacies of the military but it's my
job to explain to you like if I'm
struggling with something or if I'm an
issue with something and I'm explaining
it to you then you can be able
understand it it's just like learning I
would guess I would say that you're
right and I do a bad job of just this
exclaiming describing it so I can get
emotional because it's my family it's my
friends you know they they should I know
they love me but it's hard for me to
even put into words like the suck I
don't like doing this stuff that pushes
me mentally and physically to the
breaking point
just because yay freedom you know so
they all try but I don't do a good job
of explaining I totally agree with it's
really all about how you explain the
story and I've broken down the science
behind PTSD and why I do what I do like
you were saying I don't like to do
certain things like for instance me
whenever I go into a public restaurant
or a public like place I always have to
sit against the wall facing the front
door right because I'm always aware of
my surroundings because as a Marine
Corps infantryman I was trying to be
aware of my surroundings 360 all the
time but why though you know so I had to
explain to them why I need to sit facing
the front door whenever I go somewhere I
try to like send money to my family
every paycheck you know that's all I did
that was the one thing and I didn't like
I was trying to stay away from trouble
you know do the best I can just so I
could get the money that we needed right
one of the things when like my mom like
when I came back home she was telling me
oh why are you like this why are you
like this
it was so hard I kept explaining to her
like mom I can't explain to you that
things I had to go through in the
military that like the problems I had to
face and the things I had to endure
before you guys you know one of the
things she said as a oh it's because you
don't love me I was like whoa
that hurts so much to the point that I
was angry sad and I was like what's the
point I might move one more line over in
a second but not yet I'm gonna stay here
for me there's a positive and a negative
it was that level of discipline that
gave me the afforded to to be able to
fight through depression and anxiety and
being homeless at one point and all that
kind of stuff to get to where I'm at
today but then again like I said having
PTSD and depression and anxiety changed
me you know I spent about seven years of
my life on pause because I spent that
seven years trying to fight that mental
illness and try to get my life back so
because this is and I'm not going over
there the memories that I share with
people that are traumatic you know and
we compare notes as buddies where we
laugh and joke about it at the time and
then later on we're like wait a minute
that actually was insane and that was
horrible
you know and probably laughter and
joking about it should not be the
response settle down it's a crazy person
and that's where then I'll finally join
the smart side the dark side I didn't
feel safe sleeping you know like I felt
like I had to have like something with
me holding something I sure as hell was
alone sometimes you know but then like
it takes only one guy to say hey what's
up what can I do for you like that
connection just that initiative was all
I needed
[Music]
I don't care who the president is to be
honest with you I don't care if it's
Obama I don't care if it's Bush if it's
a president Trump I think it's a we do
this country a huge disservice by
wanting the president to do poorly when
you join the military - you don't think
like Oh who's in office oh I should wait
four more years - nobody does that
you know they just join they have their
own personal things to take care of they
don't care who was in office they're
gonna there's gonna be a job to do no
matter who's in office you know so while
I was in the Marine Corps I had the
benefit of being in a duty called
presidential support duty and I was one
of the Marines who got selected to work
in Washington DC helping protect the
president and it's like you said when
you're in the military and when I was in
that specific duty it doesn't matter who
the president is if somebody tries to
shoot at the president it's my job to
protect him or her or whoever it is them
a Kratt Republican it doesn't matter
they're the president they're the top of
the chain of command that's why I don't
want anybody to misconstrue when I say I
support the president yeah it's not that
I agree with the president I don't agree
with a lot of his like politics is you
know rhetoric and something that I don't
agree with most of it I'd say but I
still support him because it doesn't
matter to me who's in an office I want
him to do a good job yeah
for me I you know the asian guy that
came from cali something these guys have
never seen an Asian guy before and said
I was the first one besides Bruce Leon
they're going into the military it was
like there's a lot of stereotyping and a
lot of like mistreatment because of my
race or my personality or my demeanor it
might have been different for all y'all
but for me I had to go through a lot of
those obstacles and hoops but it made me
a stronger person first I mean I want to
say sorry from the side that says oh no
I didn't experience it in that
stereotype because I know that I've made
those kind of comments before maybe not
to you but to my buddies and stuff and
to us it's we're just joking
but when you're part of the maybe
majority that can be very harmful so
sorry that's okay I was in a rate or MOS
that was predominantly male and so
sometimes there's this stigma of oh she
can't lift that five-gallon drum or oh
she's just on her phone or oh she's not
paying attention and I think when you're
in a male-dominated job and you're
really trying I think it would be nice
if the male's actually pushed you more
for me it was interesting because it was
actually the opposite I experienced such
a small amount of discrimination or none
at all or even in the opposite direction
that I ended up learning from it and
growing as a human being because of it
like now I listen to country music
because of all the white guys so like
now I've actually I've expanded Who I am
because of it you know and I feel like
that has been a big part of who I've
become today
I have to think don't don't don't
I'm changing my answer I work in the
nonprofit space when I'm not doing
entertainment I have a lot of veterans
who come into my office complaining
because there's not enough resources
right now there's a trend of veterans
going to VA parking lots and committing
suicide in their cars why you know the
rate of suicides right now is around 22
a day for veterans and the veteran
community yes there are definitely
resources out there but I feel like a
lot of the resources that are out there
are very hidden and a lot of veterans
have to do hours and hours of research
to find them like a lot of the veterans
that come to my organization they tell
me we didn't even know you existed
I had no clue that this resource was an
option so I think that our country does
a lot you know what job out there
whether it be in the corporate world or
manual labor gives more to their
employees after they leave the job than
the military and one of the things that
I noticed when I separated from active
duty back in 2006 we had mandatory
classes on the last couple of days in
the military of how to maneuver those
minefields of the VA of your home loans
of GI Bill a lot of my friends blew
those classes off and didn't go to them
a lot of the veterans that come to our
company they tell us that tap sucks and
it really doesn't teach them too much
they learn the basics of like how to
write a basic resume what types of jobs
to look for and then you're thrown out
into the civilian force thrown to the
wolves so the thing is like are the
resources there absolutely do you need
to do some work to get those resources
for sure but that's like everything so
like my stance on is I think there's a
lot of veterans that they want their
hands to be held even when they get out
of service and it's like okay I
understand a part of that but at the end
of the day like you need to do some work
to get those resources and I think
there's plenty of resources if you're
willing to do the work my struggles with
anxiety and panic attacks and things
like that was like I don't want to take
medication what can I do so
I talked to Dakota Meyer who's a huge
guy in the veteran communities I'll go
get the alpha-stim every veteran center
is offering them am i jumping through
hoops to get that out fist em sure I am
is it frustrating absolutely
but the resource is still there we're in
California right so like we are
considered lucky you know I could go to
downtown LA or go to Long Beach but for
for my friends it wasn't that case a lot
of them like our state's where it's hard
to like go you have to you have to go to
another state just to get the help so I
do think that we do get the help that we
need but sometimes they don't have that
consideration from being in the military
definitely like I was definitely ready
to die for my country since I've been
out of the military and done a lot more
research went to college learned some
new things I start to question the
motives on a lot of things why we're
going to war you know like is it is it a
just cause
is it reasonable does it make sense if
the if the moment was right if there was
a reason and a good cause for me to go
and die for my country I would but I'm
not gonna leave my family behind for a
cause and I don't believe in so that's
why I somewhat agree with it strongly
for our country and I would hate to die
in a friendly fire accident or for an
unjust cause or in some craphole part of
the country or the world for maybe even
some people that don't even want us
there but I'm willing to and I feel like
you know it's important that somebody's
willing to they you know they tell you
and basic like this is you know you're
you might die and they give you
statistics or like two people in your
basic unit will probably not survive
their contract and that makes you think
like oh [ __ ] you know like that might
happen and you know that it's a
possibility
you just try not to think about it right
and that's really what it comes
- honestly you just gotta accept that
there there's might be a time for right
yeah I think there's a there's gonna be
times that war is necessary there's many
times that war is just inevitable it's
going to happen but it's unforgivable of
one of my sons were to go to war and die
for it unjust cause that's unforgivable
[Music]
it's hard to even describe how the
military changed my life because it did
it in ways that I never even knew was
was gonna happen I joined up after 9/11
and I kinda had a lot of anger a lot of
patriotism and I just thought you know
what I got to serve my country so I
joined up in the army I didn't think it
was gonna change me but it did and it
did make me think like wow I can do
anything you know I can move to
California I can get a job wherever I
want and it just gave me the confidence
to do that when I was in high school I
was one of those kids like I was lost I
really didn't know who I was I didn't
know what I wanted to do with my life
and joining the military gave me the
discipline and the maturity to be able
to figure out what path I wanted to take
as an adult for me like without the
military I wouldn't have like my degree
that I have you know I was able to go to
school I was able to buy my house with a
VA loan so like for me it's like it
really helped my life a lot joining the
military gave me more discipline and it
taught me a lot about structure that I
didn't have before and I also met the
love of my life so I can't really hate
it what's up good humans thanks so much
for watching that episode if you're an
artist we want to receive your spectrum
artwork in the next week send us your
best poster artwork to this mailing
address below we're gonna put it up in
our office and show it to all our
viewers that's right so every day we
come into the office we get to see your
beautiful work and it aspires us and
hopefully we get to inspire you and this
part of the whole movement for human
good thanks for those who have submitted
already as always make sure you like
comment subscribe we love hearing from
you follow us on Instagram and we will
see you next time
[Music]